When Disney announced they were remaking their
much-loved classic animation Beauty And The
Beast, fans wondered what exactly the new
filmmakers would keep or change and whether
the new movie could ever reach the incredibly
high bar set by the original.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and in this video, I want to take a look at
some of the very best and some of my least
favourite changes and differences between
Disney's live-action Beauty And The Beast
and the 1991 animated movie.
Naturally, I'll be delving deep into spoiler
territory, so be aware of that if you haven't
seen the new movie yet.
If that's you, you can check out my spoiler-free
review of the film by tapping or clicking
here.
I loved how they took Belle's character from
the original film and expanded and updated
it in what felt, to me, like a very natural
way.
So, Belle's still a literature-loving young
woman as she was in 1991, but she also wants
to pass that love and knowledge on to other
young girls in her town.
And not only does she help her father with
his own craft, making music boxes, like she
did with his inventions in the animation;
but she's also an inventor in her own right,
creating contraptions to make life easier
and give her more time for the things she
enjoys, like reading and sharing her knowledge.
We also see Belle firmly shutting Gaston out
of her house and plotting her escape from
the Beast's castle, and even her clothes reflect
the fact she's an active character, for example,
she wears boots and her skirt's hitched up
on one side to make riding her horse easier.
The updates to Belle's character are not only
fitting given the fact this is a film for
modern audiences, but they're also a continuation
of what began back in 1991 with Linda Woolverton,
who was the first female screenwriter of a
Disney animated feature.
Woolverton wanted Belle to be less passive,
more independent, and more relevant to contemporary
audiences than previous Disney princesses,
but often found it an uphill struggle to get
her ideas through to the final film, for example,
a scene Woolverton wrote with Belle marking
a map with all the places she wanted to visit
was switched to show Belle baking in the kitchen
until it was agreed that Belle would walk
around reading instead.
Much as I love the original animation, I think
the new filmmakers made a wise decision when
they decided not to have Gaston jump the gun
and set up a surprise wedding for Belle!
Gaston's still super-full of himself in the
new film, but what we get instead of him putting
his feet up at Belle's house and assuming
she's going to marry him, is Gaston trying
a subtler but perhaps more devious approach
by claiming to sympathise with Belle over
her mistreatment by the headmaster who put
a stop to her using her new washing invention.
It's still clear from their conversation that
they'd be hopelessly mismatched as a couple,
and there are several nice nods to the scene
from 1991, including Gaston alluding to Belle
having his children and, also, after she rebuffs
him, he walks off and steps into a muddy puddle,
a call-back to the animation where he lands
head-first in a muddy pond after Belle shows
him the door.
Gaston has many great moments in the animated
film, and Luke Evans does a fabulous job bringing
him to live-action life, giving his character
a more grounded feel than the original by
playing him so real and the comedy so deadpan.
One of the many things I love about the new
movie is Maestro Cadenza and Madame de Garderobe.
Obviously, Cadenza is a new addition to the
castle's characters, but I love how he fits
in well with the existing characters thanks
to the fact they make Garderobe his wife,
and make her human counterpart an Italian
opera diva.
Oh, and making their dog Froufou become the
Footstool character from the original movie
was also a really nice touch.
Also, their character design and the way that's
carried through into their human forms is
just wonderful.
Garderobe, especially, is a triumph of imagination.
In her wardrobe form, inside her doors, you
see stage curtains, footlights, and box seats,
all of which really bring through the fact
that, as a human being, she's a performer
and also that she has a rather dramatic, theatrical
personality.
And it's such a neat detail that after the
enchanted Cadenza has fought the angry mob
by launching his harpsichord keys at them
as if they were bullets, when he's turned
back into a human being at the end, he's missing
many of his teeth!
Audra MacDonald and Stanley Tucci, who bring
Garderobe and Cadenza to life, are just brilliant
in the film, both in their own right and together.
I love how fun their characters are, I love
the sweet way they interact with each other
in the film, I love how various easter eggs
and hidden details are introduced into the
film through their characters, I love the
very talented actors who play them, and I
love the fact their relationship adds to the
movie's diversity.
Speaking of which, Garderobe's character is
also part of another scene that adds another
element of diversity to the movie, when in
the final battle, she wraps three men in dresses
– two of whom run off, as in the animated
film, while the third is delighted to have
come out of the closet, so to speak.
Of course, there's been a lot of talk about
LeFou being gay in this film as well, with
his character experiencing mixed feelings
for Gaston and dancing briefly with a man
during the final celebration.
It's actually all very subtle, and certainly
no reason to raise the rating, cut scenes
or refuse to screen it, which is what's happened
in some parts of the world.
The film's already updating the tale for modern
audiences in terms of Belle's character and
making the cast more racially diverse, and
excluding LGBT characters from that diversity
would quite simply in my opinion be wrong.
One of the lovely touches that the filmmakers
have introduced into this movie is that as
time passes and each petal falls from the
Beast's rose, we see and hear the effects
of this on the castle and the enchanted servants.
So, Lumiere and Cogsworth's joints start to
seize up, making it harder for them to move,
the duster Plumette gets several new feathers,
and the wardrobe Garderobe becomes increasingly
sleepy and lethargic to the point where she
falls asleep after only semi-finishing a crazily
over-the-top dress for Belle.
And on several occasions, the castle itself
rumbles and creaks as various bits collapse
and fall away from its exterior.
Showing the castle and its inhabitants reacting
to the effects of the spell over time is a
beautiful and subtle addition to the movie's
world, and is perhaps a nod to how in the
Broadway musical, the effect of the spell
on the household servants shows itself gradually.
Anyway, I loved how it integrated so well
into the story and design of the movie, and
how at the end as the last petal falls, the
servants became inanimate, and later resume
their human forms in delightful ways, for
example, the duster Plumette emerges from
a pile of feathers.
Of the new songs written by composer Alan
Menken and lyricist Tim Rice for the live-action
film, my favourite is Evermore, which the
Beast sings after he sets Belle free to go
and help her father.
It's a really gorgeous musical number full
of loss, longing, and sacrifice and actor
Dan Stevens performs it so well.
And Days In The Sun, which I already liked
the first time I saw the film, really got
me the second time I watched the movie.
It's such a wonderfully melancholic lullaby-like
song sung by the enchanted servants about
their former lives and it's really very moving.
It'll be interesting to see if any of the
new songs get Oscar nominations next year.
Oh, and it's not a new song, and she just
gets a few lines, but I love hearing Audra
Macdonald as Garderobe sing Beauty And The
Beast right at the end.
She's got such a beautiful voice and presence
that it seems unbelievable that years ago
when she auditioned to be in the ensemble
for the Broadway musical of Beauty And The
Beast, she didn't get the job!
Anyway, she totally nails the song here – she's
just fantastic – and add to that the new
Beauty And The Beast lyrics that Emma Thompson
sings as Mrs Potts at the end, and it's just
perfect!
By the way, if you want to know more about
those new lyrics and how they came about,
I talk about that in my Easter Eggs video,
which you can click or tap here to watch.
One line I love in the animation that doesn't
make it into the live-action film, which I
think is a real shame, is 'Gaston, you are
positively primeval', which Belle says in
response to Gaston's comments about how women
shouldn't read as it'll give them ideas and
how she should be paying attention to more
important things than books, namely him.
What we get instead of that and Belle's refusal
when Gaston invites her to 'look at his trophies'
in the tavern, is a scene where Gaston tries
to invite himself to dinner with Belle, which
she turns down, only making the uber-arrogant
Captain even more keen.
While I did enjoy this new scene, I still
would have loved to have heard that line from
Belle in the new film.
As soon as they announced that Frozen star
Josh Gad was going to play LeFou, one image
from the animated film popped straight into
my mind.
Yes, it was the scene where LeFou, who's been
forced by Gaston to wait for Belle and Maurice
outside their house, gets covered in snow
like a snowman.
Obviously, Josh Gad's character in Frozen
is the snowman Olaf, so I was really hoping
they'd recreate that snowman scene from the
1991 movie, even though I knew it would be
such an obvious joke and that alone would
mean they probably wouldn't do it!
In the end, because of the way they've changed
the story in the new film, the events that
lead up to that snowman scene in the animated
movie wouldn't make sense here, but I would
still have loved to have seen Josh Gad in
live-action snowman form!
But despite the fact I didn't get my Snow-Gad
in the movie, I think Josh Gad is superb in
Beauty And The Beast and works so well together
with Luke Evans as Gaston.
One moment in the film that didn't seem as
natural or smoothly executed as the rest to
me was when Belle meets Lumiere.
In the original film, Lumiere introduces himself
to her before the big song-and-dance number,
Be Our Guest.
But in this film, she meets him earlier when
he goes to her cell and offers to escort her
to her room.
Belle seems a bit more taken aback in this
version when she meets the enchanted servants
for the first time, but that's not my issue
with the change, as it'd be perfectly normal
for her to be shocked to see a talking candelabra
for the first time.
What didn't work for me in this new scene
was the way her reaction to him seems delayed
or a bit disjointed.
What I mean is that she's already seen him
and talked to him, but she still decides to
go ahead and hit him with a stool and then
after that she also screams.
I can see what they were trying to do with
the scene, and how they were also echoing
Maurice's reaction to Lumiere from the 1991
film, but the way the scene's been put together
here is incoherent, as if it wasn't edited
or scripted quite right, so it ended up not
ringing true for me.
When I first saw the trailers for Beauty And
The Beast, I've gotta say I wasn't super-keen
on the look of the enchanted objects, especially
Mrs Potts.
I mean, I just love how expressive she looks
in the animated version, and in the new film,
she seems less so, and on top of that, of
course, the animated Mrs Potts has a spout
for a nose, whereas the spout on the live-action
Mrs Potts is there as a sort of arm, which
may have been inspired by her design in the
Broadway musical.
When did I see the full live-action film for
the first time, I've gotta admit that the
production design did win me over as the rather
ornate and refined design of the objects fits
well with the mid-17th-century time setting
they've chosen for the film.
Still, as much as I love Emma Thompson's rendition
of 'Tale As Old As Time' and her lively take
on Mrs Potts, that role will still always
belong to Angela Lansbury for me.
As for Ewan McGregor as Lumiere, while I did
enjoy the overall performance, especially
the 'Be Our Guest' extravaganza, it does sound
like he had a tough time with the French accent,
and he's actually said as much himself.
So, again, much as I love Lumiere and the
new movie as a whole, it's still Jerry Orbach's
animated Lumiere that wins the day for me.
And I'd say the same for Nathan Mack's take
on Chip in the live-action movie versus Bradley
Pierce's animated Chip as well.
Now, I'd love to hear your verdict about the
changes between the original animation and
Disney's live-action remake.
What did you most enjoy and what didn't you
like?
Let me know in the comments below.
And while you're here, why not be my guest
and enjoy some of my other Beauty And The
Beast videos including 17 easter eggs & hidden
details you might have missed in the new movie
and 10 movie mistakes and plot holes from
the animation that the new movie fixed.
You can tap or click here to watch any of
those and check out my full playlist.
Thanks for watching and see you next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers.